so usually my routine is I get up at
5:00 and Sharon and I read you know read
through several news blogs and different
things and sit and sometimes we'll talk
about you know what's going on in the
news we laugh because we sit and look at
our computers and that kind of feels
like we're not relational but really
that's how you read the paper nowadays
and so we're sitting with you know with
our machines in our lap with a cup of
coffee sitting there at five o'clock in
the morning the sun's coming up and
we're reading through those and I'll
jump through and check emails they came
in overnight I can't keep from doing
that and I'll jump through and check you
know what's happening on Twitter for the
fun of it and so you know I was reading
through the Twitter feed this morning
this guy asked a great question it was
actually a little bit later in the
morning than that when I jumped back
over on there but he said in our Bible
study this morning we were talking about
this he said what's the difference
between ambition and discontentment
great question and you know I think what
happens is around the whole subject of
contentment or ambition oftentimes
Christians get a serious level of
weirdness going on you get screwed up as
if it's wrong to be ambitious as a
Christian as if it's as if you're if
you're ambitious or you're a go-getter
you're someone that gets things done
that somehow that indicates you're not
content and so you can't confuse sitting
on your butt with contentment they're
not the same thing Paul said I've
learned to be content in all things when
I have when I'm when I'm in plenty and
when I have lack and the Bible says do
nothing out of selfish ambition and so I
thought it was a really good question
that this guy's asking because I think a
lot of people particularly those that
run in the groups that I run in the
evangelical Christian group really get
this whole thing screwed up as if being
ambitious means automatically you're
discontent
now so here's what I thought about
number one
some
that are ambitious are ambitious for the
wrong reasons the thing that's driving
their ambition is some kind of broken
place in them and that could be
discontentment so some ambition is
driven by discontentment and that is not
good ambition some ambition is selfish
ambition its ambition to gather up just
apology stuff for me
that's stuff itis and Bible speaks
directly to that do nothing out of
selfish ambition but there is there are
positive types of ambition as well that
have nothing to do with this contentment
in the sense of I'm not contented in my
own life but what if you said I'm
ambitious too I've got a friend of mine
who is a big-time national politician
that's a Christian and I asked him one
time why he does that because he makes
no money and he puts up with
unbelievable crap off of you people and
I and it hardly ever gets anything done
because doing stuff as a politician it's
just ridiculous it's very hard to get
things done he said I feel like God has
called me into this role well I'm not
arguing with that and he said the things
that I can get done I can get good
things done that I couldn't get done
were I in business instead of politics
and so I see this as an act of service
and so what what is his ambition well if
he's telling the truth and I know him
well enough to know that he is telling
the truth in his case he's doing he's
got an ambition to help change the
nation for the good that's a positive
ambition what if you're a teacher and
you're an ambitious teacher and your
ambition is to make sure that the kids
in your classroom read and you're more
ambitious than any other teacher about
that that's not selfish ambition that's
ambition for others it's ambition for
changing the lives of those kids what if
you're a counselor and your ambition is
to is to try to save marriages and you
do marriage counseling
it's wonderful ambition and so all
ambition is not negative and all
ambition is not paradoxical to someone
that is a person of faith because
sometimes we feel I mean the dumbing
down of people in Christianity sometimes
it's just ridiculous by that I mean
we're told you know well you just have
to you know you can't you have to be
humble and and and what that what does
they don't even know what humble is what
they mean is you have to be humiliated
you have to be a worm I'm just a worm
well I'm not a worm I'm a child of God
you might be a worm but I'm not a worm
and I was made for something great and
it says that clearly in Scripture but we
don't gravitate to those kinds of
scriptures often enough
instead we gravitate to them this is oh
I'm a moment sooner yeah we are saved by
grace by goodness hello think about that
I'm an overcomer as what I am and so you
know I don't want us to say that people
who get things done aren't spiritual
people people who have confidence aren't
spiritual people you should have
confidence
you shouldn't have arrogance but some of
you can't tell the difference I get
emails all the time you're so arrogant
you're just arrogant how can you say
you're a Christian you're so arrogant
people put that crap the haters put that
crap on Twitter all the time and you
know what it's just because you can't
tell the difference between arrogance
and confidence and you haven't met
anybody that was confident so long you
don't know how to act when you do meet
one because most people walk around
looking like they were weaned on a
pickle hey if you're happy notify your
face try smiling it's a good idea do
nothing out of selfish ambition but
here's a challenge for you be excellent
be passionate about your excellence be
ambitious in your service to your family
be an ambitious husband and how you
serve your wife be an ambitious wife and
how you serve your husband be ambitious
in your parent
be ambitious in your career that you go
and you do good for others in the
marketplace and be ambitious when you
catch the cheque and don't apologize for
winning anymore see that's cool that's
different than this contentment great
great question
thanks for tweeting that to me I
appreciate it this is the Dave Ramsey
show